ما زالت قضيه اتهام حكيمي بالاغتصاب تثير
ضجه بتداعياتها اخرها كانت طرد مذيع
كولومبي شهير من وظيفته بعد دفاعه عن
اللاعب المغربي وانتقاده للفتاه التي ذهبت
لمنزل حكيمه لكن ان كانت تعامل مع من
يدافع عن متهما بالاغتصاب بهذا الشكل
فلماذا المعني بالامر وهو حكيمي ما زال
حرا طليقا على عكس مثلا البرازيلي داني
الفيس الذي يقبع خلف القضبان وهو يواجه
تهما مماثله لتلك الموجهه لحكيمه حسب
تقارير فانما يجعل حاله حكيم مختلفه عن
حاله الفاز هو سلوك الضحيه المزعوم عند
الابلاغ عن الواقعه ففي حاله اللعب
البرازيلي ابلغت الضحيه عن اغتصابها بمجرد
مغادرتها الملهى الليلي بينما الفتاه التي
اشتكت حكيمي لم ترغب في تقديم شكوى رسميه
ورفضت مواجهه اللاعب
السيناريو الذي ترجعه محاميه حكيم استمرت
القضيه بهذا الشكل مع تمسك موكلها ببراءته
هو سحب الفتاه الاتهاماتها في قضيه قد
تستمر لاشهر وبالرغم من ان حكيمي حر طليق
ومستمر في العمل وناديه باريس سان جيرمان
يدعمه لكنه خسر زوجته هبه ابوك بسبب هذه
الاتهامات التي تقول تقارير انها مدمره
نفسيا بعد انتشار المزاعم الاغتصاب فيما
تحدثت مصادر عن وجود مشاكل بين الزوجين
لكن المزاعم جاءت لتسرع من اجراءات انفصال
الثنائي
[موسيقى]